[Musique]
et bien sûr la chronique du lundi avec
michael et le mindoro bonsoir vous nous
présenter les résultats l'actualité
sportive du week-end un sport dont on ne
parle pas souvent nickel c'est le
crossfit le vélodrome qui était plein à
craquer ce week-end des sportifs ultra
musclé à rythme effréné la fièvre du
crossfit a gagné le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant
trois jours la structure accueilli pour
la toute première fois
le crossfit french soit donne la
compétition a attiré près de 9000
personnes dans l'enceinte
on écoute l'un des organisateurs au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
moi je suis anglais j'ai fait ce genre
de boulot dans toutes ces pays les
infrastructures ici sont exceptionnelles
comme la flexibilité de l'équipe aussi
nous permettent de concerts on a
construit un stade à l'extérieur on a un
village partenaires mais comment se
déroulait la compétition alors plusieurs
catégories étaient au programme des
moins de 18 ans plus de 50 ans total 540
participants venus de 47 pays se sont
affrontés à travers une dizaine
d'épreuves qui met à la fois force
endurance précision et vitesse
on écoute les réactions même ma
catégorie eric saade très gros niveau
donc ouais c'est un honneur d'être ici
c'était vraiment un événement réussi
pour moi c'est le maire événements en
europe qui n'existe pas il très haut
très haut je pensé quoi que ce soit que
ce soit si haut niveau ça nous pousse
même nous les plus petit pour devenir
grand et plus fort donc offert un très
très gros niveau est très intéressant
je pensais pas avoir autant de monde ici
et c'est vraiment bien ça montre que
proscrite a beaucoup d'importance
les meilleurs ont remporté un chèque de
dix mille euros et le droit de
participer au crossfit games
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de la
discipline
mais le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs discutent déjà d'un
éventuel retour vais au tour national de
saint quentin en yvelines mais
décidément dans cette chronique la part
belle à des pratiques originales une
compétition après le creux suite avait
aussi une compétition insolite
c'est ça une équipe versaillaise baptisé
titanic a participé aux red bull jourdan
vol le week-end dernier à lyon une
compétition délurée où les participants
doivent propulser leur ovni du haut
d'une plate forme de six mètres après
une petite chorégraphie des jack et rose
d'un jour sont ensuite notés par un jury
regardez cet extrait de leur compétition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont finalement terminé à la 14e
place sur 32
comme quoi comme quoi merci michael on
vous retrouve bien sûr dans votre
émission dans un instant le 7-8 sport
sur tv 78